what's going on guys national master james cantor
third here with chess.com and today we have game
of the day with the white pieces we have ariana
tari and with the black pieces we have magnus
carlsen let's get right into it guys here we go
e4 and c5 a sicilian let's see which one knight of
three at knight to c6 d4 and c takes d4 now after
c takes d4 there is knight takes d4 and knight f6
here looking like it's going to be a special cough
like magnus played against fabiano carowanna in
the world championship so after knight f6 there is
knight to c3 and instead of the shreznikov that he
probably is prepared for he plays d6 which is very
very flexible here so let's see how he proceeds
after bishop to g5 which is a very aggressive move
here just stating that hey i'm going to attack you
maybe play stuff like f4 maybe even castle queen
side and launch an attack now after bishop to g5
there's bishop to d7 just wanting to bring our
rook to the file and also developing as well
after bishop d7 there is queen to d2 as it
looks like he's gonna go for this immediate
capsule queen side and just launch my pawns at
you and after queen to d2 there's a6 preparing b5
and stopping anything from white coming to the b5
square as well after a6 there is castle's queen
side and we do have e6 here guys nothing else but
e6 very flexible take notes here you want to have
flexibility and you want to have options in your
game here e6 is not telling anything it's only
saying that we're going to put our bishop here
on e7 but we don't know if we're going to play d5
later if we're going to play e5 if we're going to
push any of these at all maybe at the right moment
maybe we'll be able to push these but this is a
very flexible um opening now at the same time you
do have less space and when you have less space
you will be more cramped so let's see what happens
after e6 f4 by white here by ariana and just
playing aggressive e5 could be a thing eventually
luckily that b5 square is covered by us because
things like bishop to b5 or even capturing and
playing e5 could be annoying sometimes so after f4
we have bishop to e7 getting our pieces off of the
back rank and blocking this file at the same time
or diagonal we have knight to f3 very interesting
move by ariane guys if you have more space you
want to do less trades and if you have less
less space you want to do more trades so knight f3
is a very common move in these type of positions
just keeping the space we don't want to trade
and if we do capture then we could take with
the bishop and e4 is attacked rook to c8 still
coming and actually black's doing just fine here
now after knight f3 black's like let's go for it
it's that time b5 let's go now our king is still
in the center here we haven't committed to the
king side but we are starting our attack already
in like night or fashion so for all the night or
fans out there this is very very similar in your
type of play with a b5 and maybe even bringing
the queen over to a6 to a5 or b6 and something
something to do with the knight maybe knight to b4
in some cases and rook to ca and just start this
queen side attack out of nowhere after bishop to
f6 which is a very interesting move here honestly
you do have to do something with his bishop h6
is coming and if you just back up you could but
that's just not what we wanted to do so after
bishop takes f6 guys g takes f6 so you don't
lose the pawn on d6 d6 is absolutely hanging
so he takes with the pawn here stay uh stop and
take a look at this position just just look at it
what is going on here how do you feel about this
and how do you feel about white's position here
guys this is very very advanced chess as these are
both very strong grand masters now check this out
guys in this kind of structure here black is doing
just fine but he is definitely defending he's
trying to figure out what he wants to do here and
he's going to adapt over white of what white does
so let's see what happens after g takes f6 there's
king to b1 king to b1 is always a good move they
always say always play king b1 or king b8 if you
capture queenside and you haven't put your king
on the b file yet you usually aren't fully castled
yet because things like rook to c8 is extremely
annoying and vice versa if you're playing black
and there's a rook on b1 eyeing the king that may
be on uh the c file actually not the b file you
want to put the king on the b file as quickly as
possible after you cast the queenside queen to b6
he gets the queen out of the way is he preparing
the castle queenside well let's see after f5 which
is a very strong move here just saying hey i'm
going to break some stuff up maybe g4 is coming
and we're just going to attack you as much as we
can now black's doing just fine here but it does
take precision and accuracy now after f5 there
is a capsule queen side here guys how many of
you would have castled kingside that would have
been extremely bad here after queen h6 is almost
almost just destroying and then after follow like
rook to d3 and rook to g3 with the king on g8
this is already lights out have a good day right
so after f5 he castle queen side which is very
interesting you see these kind of open dynamic
castle queen side in an open kind of position with
a messed up pawn structure kind of position
in semi-slots so if you play the simi slot
sometimes even the slop you have a similar
position like this where it gets extremely sharp
after capsule queen side we do have bishop to d3
guys you gotta develop your pieces no matter what
and then we have king to b8 as we see they both
put your kings on the b file guys i mean when you
you can't fully castle until you put your king on
the b file when you castle a queen side now after
king to ba there's knight to e2 just a little
bit of rearranging and making sure our pieces are
better once you develop your pieces you need to go
back and then you have to figure out what is the
best place for my pieces so if you look at this
knight it literally had no squares to go to so
he's just going to reroute it to a better side of
the board or even somewhere where he can be active
now we have bishop ca very nice move he's doing
the same thing this bishop was very very bad it's
not doing anything it's actually blocking this
file as well so he's just gonna move it out of the
way maybe we'll put it here maybe we'll move it
back let's see so then he plays knight to f4 aryan
is actually just going to reroute the knight just
like we saw here he moved it to e2 and now to f4
just to put a little bit of pressure on the center
here and then knight to e5 by magnus i really like
this move here just opening up the game we do have
less space so what do you look for guys trades and
especially in the sicilians guys sicilians are
very very nice for black when we do get trades
and go into end games where we could be slightly
better due to our position and pawn structures
bishop to e2 for aryan and then an interesting
move here from black guys if you look at this
position there's a there's a lot of dynamicism to
it what would you actually play in this position
here we go black shows d5 i like d5 here it's
a very very strong move guys is breaking up
the center breaking up the center the rooks
are uh connected here they're defended so
after e takes d5 we take the pawn the other
way we don't even take on d5 are you serious
what is this it's triple pawns this is the world
champion with three triple pawns on the f file
this is insane what do you mean why would you
even take this way after i looked at this game
this was very very very very interesting i like
this a lot because he voluntarily he voluntarily
tripled his pawns here on the f file knight to
d4 it seems like black is like in trouble is
what it feels like here i mean there's holes in
the position but we have two bishops that are
sharp and two bishops are an advantage here but
we do have triple pawns guys insane triple pawns
so let's see what he does about it he plays
bishop c5 he gets a little bit aggressive here
let's see what's going to happen it's going to
get really crazy in a second rook 8 still f1
rook h2e8 here getting our last piece into the
game and then after a3 now this one is is hard
this is a hard move to make guys what would you
play here what would you play with magnus carlsen
as black what would you play after a3 he made
a waiting move which was really cool king 2a
maybe even some prophylaxis there maybe if he
wants to move the knight and stopping any checks
that may be able to get here eventually but he
played king to a8 more of like a waiting move
but also prophylaxis maybe even putting a rook on
the b file eventually let's see what happens king
a8 and h3 interesting move maybe just trying to
play g4 just trying to do something at the end of
the day we do have to make a move here and after
bishop to d7 he moves it back looks like we're
preparing rook to b8 the knight to h5 he's like
okay time to attack f6 is not hanging because it
is defended but f5 is hanging and this is triple
pawns guys we got triple pawns this isn't that fun
the knight to c4 you have to play aggressive if
you look at the night or type positions you will
always see this 95 knight to c4 queens on b6 or c7
and a rook coming to the final aiming at this side
of the board it's an all out king hunt knight to
c4 bishop takes c4 b takes c4 and then queen to c3
let's see let's take a look of inventory here
what's going on we have two bishops for black
we have triple pawns on the file and the knight is
two nights for the one or two two nights for white
and um and two rooks and a queen so after queen to
c3 we have rook to b8 hitting the b2 pawn so the
queen's kind of trapped not really not trapped
but he can't move from c4 or c3 if you take on
c4 there's checkmate on b2 so let's actually see
what he does to untangle he plays rook 2f3 here
and now guys this is a very highlight moment
this is a big boy move hopefully you did your
tactics today if you have and if you haven't
then this is the time black to move guys what
would you play magnus carlsen lifted his piece
and played what in this position if you said
rook to e1 oh my goodness wow what is on the
board rook to e1 can you even do that is that
even legal rook to e1 look at this move guys if
queen takes e1 self-explanatory queen takes b2
that's already done have a nice day so he takes
with the rook because it's forced there's nothing
really else to do after rook takes e1 bishop
takes d4 wow look at the pressure on the b
two pawn this was a beautiful move here guys rook
to e1 make sure you do your tactics and look for
the moves that you don't think are possible and he
found it rookie one and bishop takes d4 and then
we have queen to b4 just blocking the file you
have to do something because this is going to get
very scary then he moves his queen to c7 and again
guys we have triple pawns here but what a decisive
attack here amazing how he moved his king to aa
put the rook on ba open the file by playing knight
to c4 and use every single piece to attack the
king a beautiful display a master at work here or
grand master at work world champion at work queen
to c7 and d6 you take my queen i take yours but
i'll be winning so let's play queen to c6 and get
out of the way after queen to a5 here bishop to b
bishop takes b2 it's going to get very crazy here
let's see what happens in the next few moves king
to a2 and bishop to e5 as rook to b2 is definitely
on the way so he plays rook to b1 and says not
today rook takes king takes and then queen takes
d6 take a quick inventory we're down in exchange
here with black but we have bishops and a weak
king here with may threats literally everywhere
on the board literally everywhere so all kind of
things are happening i mean even queen of b8 could
be very scary as well so king to c1 he gets out
of the way and then we have queen d4 centralized
the queen there's a check here there's a check
here there's a check everywhere he voluntarily
gives up the pawn and says hey well you don't
have any other checks you can't play rook to
b3 that would be disastrous but he can't play
it and you can't just do it with your queen you
don't even have a check you don't have a check wow
just gave up the pawn to get more initiative here
and then c3 by white and here we go guys watch
the precision queen g1 king d2 queen takes g2
your rooks hanging king to e3 now it's defended
f4 use every piece we have on the board and after
knight takes bishop takes rook takes hey we're out
of the woods here we're feeling great we got that
exchange we're still up this exchange or are we
up the exchange anymore he gets it right back here
beautiful beautiful way a display of moves here
as he's able to come back here check queenie one
best move here because queen e5 is made if you go
king f4 i mean beautiful geometry of the squares
here queen e5 king takes c4 queen e4 check king
to c5 i take the rook and now you're down a piece
not it up in exchange anymore not enough checks
here for a perpetual we can always just black
block as well um but maybe yeah we could block
maybe we could block but if czech king here is
probably the best to be honest and after king to
d6 we have bishop to c8 and then aryan resigned
right in this position guys there's really nothing
you can do after queen here queen to be a b6 we
just come back and block and honestly we're fine
and we're winning we're up material here and this
game is going to be over very soon so ariane
resigned right here in this position what a
game here guys this was amazing display of just
sit back and wait and then start to attack adapt
over your opponent's position and adapt to what
they do and find the best moves like rookie one
the ones that you didn't even think about and this
was a beautiful display by magnus carlson i am
national master james canty iii and this was game
of the day and i'll see you guys on the next video